Amazon boss gets involved and tells MGM
to hurry up welcome to S check your saat
evm movie
Janel so if you are a regular sidet
tracker you'll know we've been talking
about Stargate for two and a half years
and all of the different rumors and all
the different false starts we've had
with bringing back one of our favorite
sci-fi franchises but this rumor is not
just about Stargate it's about things
like RoboCop it's about things like a
Forbidden Planet remake it's things like
some sort of 2001 reboot it is about
mgm's vast assortment of back catalog
the reason why Amazon bought MGM in the
first place it's about James Bond it's
about a million other things so what has
actually happened well one of the
sources I speak to actually works at
Culver City Studios now Culver City is a
very large studio complex but it's also
where Amazon pictures headquarters is
and they actually have several Studio
spaces there themselves the rumor and I
have to say specifically that this is a
rumor is that Mike Hopkins who is
Jennifer s's immediate boss and Jennifer
salki being the current head of MGM
Amazon Studios did have a meeting at
Culver City with Jennifer saly and
several other Executives on the second
of January the rumor part comes in
though about what that meeting was about
so the rumor that is going around the
building at Culver City and is being
whispered by the staff around the water
cooler is that Mike Hopkins was there to
basically tell Jennifer suy off now I
don't think for a second this was a
banging tables and you idiots type of
thing but more of a why are we still
waiting on these projects why is this
happening why is this happening come on
get something going and apparently
according to the rumor my Hopkins has
has insisted that Amazon MGM pictures
announce something coming out of the MGM
back catalog now he wants something big
announced immediately now that could be
Bond it could be Stargate it could be
something else but my Hopkins has
basically now said I've had enough of
this to be honest like we have we've
been waiting 18 months for a big MGM
announcement and we've had nothing get
on with it I don't care if it's RoboCop
Stargate Bond get me something now to me
that is music to my ears because I've
been as frustrated as many of you we
keep hearing about these false starts we
keep hearing about rumors regarding
Stargate and bond and other things but
nothing ever seems to happen now there
have been good reasons for that so let's
talk about why are we actually delayed
at the moment and what is a lot of the
sources that I speak to telling me about
particularly while we're still waiting
on Stargate something that yes I'm
obsessed about well we are 99% certain
we were going to get a cinematic movie
announced at San Diego ComicCon in June
2023 the strikes basically stopped that
from happening but what was the actual
plan if you're enjoying the video don't
forget to like subscribe and hit that
Bell notification so you miss none of
our new videos and most importantly
leave a comment it's a community after
all we want to know what you think too
well we strongly believe that a script
has been done and that there is a
partner involved that we're going to
co-produce this project with Amazon
pictures and MGM we believe they're
actually going to be filming in Eastern
Europe and we've had a couple of sources
come forward and said they even saw some
of the pre-production work we believe
the special effects were going to be
done in Germany and again a couple of
different sources have come forward and
said that actually they were aware of
that contract agreement but those
agreements were cancelled when the
strikes happened around March or early
April Amazon actually decided not to
announce the project and to start
delaying some of the bigger projects
because they realized the strikes were
going to happen and they were going to
end up having to delay anyway so they
paused now this project was going to be
filmed at Studio space in Eastern Europe
that Amazon were going to be renting now
sound stages Etc are very expensive so
during the pause while the strikes were
going on Amazon decided to accelerate
its plans to get hold of its own Studio
spaces now this is being done through an
agreement with the Hackman Group which
is the world's largest private owner of
Studio space and Amazon were going to
have longterm deals to rent many of
those spaces off Hackman it should be
noted that Hackman actually built the
Amazon Studio headquarters and the
studio spaces that they use currently at
Culver City Now One Source I've spoken
to says that this will allow Amazon to
cut nearly 10% off its production costs
for anything and when you're talking
about something like bond which will
probably cost2 200 million to make if
you can cut 10% off those production
costs that's at least a $20 million
saving that's not to be sniffed at even
something like starget which we suspect
would be around an 80 7080 million
budget something like that you're
talking about 789 million saving again
very very worth having the problem is
though that a lot of that studio space
isn't yet available and won't be
available till the summit of this year
now that leads into my prediction that I
actually think Stargate in particular
will be announced San Diego ComicCon in
June 2024 and production will then start
in the late summer I'm sure we'll hear
lots of rumors between now and then but
I think that will happen because that's
when the studio space that Amazon want
is available and when they can start
seeing those savings by using their own
Studio space so why is Mike Hopkins in
there telling them to hurry up well it's
just been delay after delay and the fans
are getting frustrated I see it through
my comments that people are getting
insanely frustrated by the Stargate
project but also James Bond it's been a
couple of years now since the last James
Bond movie and we're still waiting on
announcement on who will be the next
Bond we had a bunch of rumors last year
spin round but then then nothing has
happened again I think nothing's
happened because Amazon are delaying but
my Hopkins is sick of those delays now
he wants something to get announced so
that we can start moving forwards even
if that announcement is that yes we're
doing this but it won't start filming
until the summer well another reason and
another reason why Mike Hopkins isn't
impressed is that actually Amazon
weren't prepared when the strikes ended
to restart production on even the stuff
that had already gone into production
the rumor again is that they let a lot
of the private studos bace that they
were renting go they didn't want to pay
for it during the strikes and then when
the strikes ended apparently a little
sooner than they were expecting they
didn't have access to that studio space
and couldn't get it quickly enough
apparently it's only now nearly three
months after the strikes actually ended
that they're getting back up to capacity
that would even allow them to do what
they'd already started so that's just
one more thing Mike Hopkins apparently
is not particularly impressed by
he wants to know what the hell is going
on at MGM Amazon pictures he wants an
explanation like we all do and hopefully
he got it that Mike Hopkins turning up
and laying down the lore a little bit
I'm sure very politely as L fire under
their backsides and just maybe we'll get
to see some movement in the new year a
little bit quicker than maybe they were
planning but guys what do you think is
it a surprise that MGM has announced
really nothing in the 18 months since
Amazon bought it the whole point of
Amazon buying MGM was that it was going
to exploit all of this lovely
intellectual property that MGM owns
exploits this back catalog of nearly a
hundred years worth of movies and it's
done
nothing is that a shark or is that just
business is that the strikes is that
Amazon having to get more Studio space
is it boring but just the way business
is get to the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the channel pleasee like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com sidre which is where most of
our new videos Premiere first and you
get to see them without the adverts you
lucky bunnies also you can go to s.o.
which is our dedicated website and we do
storage based on a lot of our videos you
we try to add a little bit more
information for the for you to digest
there so go check that out too as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time now that bit we know happened the
rum apart comes in to what the staff
over at Culver City are Whispering
around the water Coy the water
[Music]